- I'm going to take a quiz and find out
how Irish I am, or I'm going to make my
Irish ancestors roll in their graves.
(jaunty Irish music)
- My mom did a DNA test
about two years ago and
found out that she is literally
50% English and 50% Irish.
- I'm descended from the
Duke of Abbot who was
an heir to the throne
back in 14th century.
- My great-grandmother, Frances,
came over on a boat from Ireland.
- I am not very culturally Irish.
- I have green hair.
- I do drink a lot of beer though.
- The answer's no, not
culturally Irish at all.
What is the significance
of St. Patrick's Day?
- Oh God, what did Saint Patrick do?
- Ooh, okay.
- He's like Santa's brother
or something, Saint Nick.
- The Catholics versus the Protestants.
- There were snakes.
- The snakes are
Protestants; it's a metaphor.
- Saint Patrick drove all of
the snakes out of Ireland.
- St. Patrick's Day is March 17th.
- It's March 17th, I know that.
- I believe it is the
second Sunday in March.
- Which of the following
is not a place in Ireland?
- Doodys Bottoms
- Slutsend
- Muff (laughs)
- Clitheroe
- Or, Cum?
- Wow! Don't show my mom
this, this is so dirty.
Okay, this is the city I
don't think exists in Ireland.
- Clitheroe is in
England, that makes sense.
Pronounce the following names (sighs)
This is where it all falls apart.
- Shi-vawn
- Show-bin
- [Interviewer] Shi-vawn.
- Shi-vawn?
- Shi-bawn I know, that one I have.
- That's how you guys spell Siobhan?
- Nam?
- Ny-me
- Nee-um?
- [Interviewer] Neev.
- Neev?
- Oh of course, yeah.
- Cay-ohm, no.
- Cave?
- Cay-o-heem?
- Ky-eev? (laughs)
- [Interviewer] Nailing it.
- Celeste? (laughs)
- [Interviewer] Quee-va.
- Quee-va?
- (laughs) Of course it is.
- Spell the following names.
- This is going to be bad;
I can't spell anything.
- [Interviewer] The first name is Aoife.
- Ee-fa.
- I've never felt so defeated in my life,
and I've taken three Bar Exams.
- Now if I know anything
about Gaelic, it's that
the letters do not
correspond to the sounds.
- Sive.
- S-I-E
Hold on, say it again, who's right?
- Name three Irish celebrities.
- Saoirse Ronan.
- Is Liam Neeson Irish?
- Liam Neeson.
- Bono.
- Oh, Bono!
- Someone from Game of Thrones.
- Saoirse Ronan.
- Is Colin Farrell Irish?
- Colin Farrell?
- Do I get half a point for just knowing
that the guy who was in In Bruges
who is not Colin Farrell is, wait,
oh is Colin Farrell, is he Irish? Yes!
- Read these lyrics in an Irish accent.
I knew I was going to have
to do an Irish accent.
- There is not enough alcohol in the world
to get me to do this, I am sorry.
- [Interviewer] Try,
just commit. Two lines.
- I mean, I could sing this song.
Let's do it in the style of
Littlefinger from Game of Thrones.
♪Oh, Danny boy, the pipes,
the pipes are calling ♪
♪From glen to glen, and
down the mountain side ♪
♪The summer's gone,
all the roses falling ♪
(record scratches)
- I'm so so sorry.
♪It'll be there in sunshine or shadow ♪
♪Oh, Danny boy, oh Danny
boy, I love you so! ♪
- I did better than I thought.
The song at the end really
kind of put me over the top.
- Hey! Do they raise the roof in Ireland?
- 33 ish percent or so, I'll take it.
- Everyone who's watching from Ireland,
I just want to say that I'm sorry.
- I'm sorry.
- I'm so sorry, I really--
- I do claim Irish heritage, but
apparently I have not earned it.
- You're a beautiful country with
a lot of culture, and
you have given so much--
- Please don't hold this video against me.
(slow Irish music)